shot being fired off a victim down
eyewitnesses say someone fired shots at
members of Congress this morning the
congressman who was shot in the hip
Steve Scalise he is the Republican House
Majority Whip a number of members of
Congress stunned and devastated
an attack on one of us is an attack on
all of us
there are numerous police cars he laid
out there for at least 10 minutes alone
in the field and we just think we
couldn't get to him the salient has now
died from his injuries he was shot
multiple times in his chest
jurors ordered takeout here to the
courthouse and deliberated the Cosby's
very competent company and his legal
team that were captured by the
fraternity's own surveillance cameras
were chilling sure we didn't call for
help can call that charged with that
this fire happened it happened in the
middle of the night we could take people
screaming help me help me strong
forceful that gave sound bites that
showed up on the news you're not
answering questions would be
inappropriate to reveal private
conversations with the president Earnie
general jeff sessions he was being very
very quiet
[Music]
so give me this it was one of the most
anticipated finals rematches since well
last season's Finals rematch no bus I
love everything I on the floor every
single game you come up short it's fun
to watch Kevin Durant's mom he said he
told her he's eight that this was going
to happen away she grabs his goatee and
said look at me well we had very little
talent actually he was mostly coaching I
knew they needed a host the competition
for a Tony Award was a welcome change
shut that crap off I just want to say I
just want to say one is a transgender
marathon activist comedian and the other
and the other is the CEO of Price
Waterhouse Cooper which is who Jason is
bull tells us how having a daughter
changed his life on tour girls change
your life don't they I do the Rose will
change your life in a really good way -
happy happy happy Mary not letting me
eat something a whole
his pipe whatever getting out of prison
the and/or Weston the game is on
throughout the whole game we will all be
teamed scalise by playing tonight you
are showing the world that we will not
be intimidated by threats America
doesn't give out America doesn't give in
I did tell Joe that I loved him before
the game and I loved him after the game
but during the game we're going to play
to win this game is over the Democrats
back in the win column whether you're
Republican or Democrat it's still a
family
[Music]
[Applause]
you